on reçoit un mail à midi pour dire la
piscine ne réouvrira pas à 14 heures
donc ce qui est quand même c'est quand
même inédit quand on est maire on a un
seul boulot c'est de garantir le
fonctionnement des services publics que
les balayeurs les ordures ménagères que
les cantinières dans les écoles la
police au carrefour que tout le monde
soit là à son poste là on a négocié un
prix avec une entreprise et l'entreprise
nous dit bah ça m'arrange plus trop le
prix fixe c'est vraiment pas avantageux
jeu les cartes mais si vous voulez
réouvrir c'est à vous de payer donc
quand on top quand on signe un contrat
on le respecte c'était fou inclus berdai
c'est incroyable cette histoire parce
que il faut savoir que ces piscines là
elles sont accessibles aux petits porte
monnaie ça va toucher des gens modestes
et xavier on voit leurs enfants les gens
des clubs les écoles vont plus pouvoir y
aller donc cette société là moi je
trouve que vous avez raison d'aller en
justice parce que elle touche au coeur
nos enfants des gens modestes qui ne
vont plus pouvoir bientôt exercer
d'activités aquatiques trouve ça
scandaleux après on peut tout entendre
un jeu évidemment le prix l'électricité
est à multiplier par dix ces ramenant
donc c'est vrai que ja c'est pas soit ce
fait nous on envoie des entreprises qui
commencent à fermer comme dans la région
je suis élu duralex le cas sur le
verrier bas les fours à gaz pour des
verreries ils arrêtent de la production
mais le problème c'est qu'ils font
parler à l'avancé qu'il faut garantir le
service public puisqu'il ya les
scolaires et les crises et du on va le
dire au tpc dus essentiellement gilles
verdez à la guerre en ukraine 1 voilà
oui absolument alors la société dit que
sa facture globale est passée de 15 à
l'interview millions d'euros oui à cause
de la guerre en ukraine qui a fait
monter les tarifs effectivement donc
c'est le différentiel est énorme mais
pour moi je pense que cette société
peut-être qu'on sait que les piscines ça
coûte cher à faire fonctionner et je me
suis demandé gère d'avoir votre réponse
là dessus est-ce que c'est pas un
prétexte ça est ce que la société joue
pas un peu de ça à votre avis moi je
pense qu'elle est en discussion avec
l'état sur des airs oui elle s'essaye
donc ils prennent aussi en otage sans
doute sur les collectivités parce qu'ils
arrêtent les piscines dont les prix ont
été négociés à prix fixe ok mais il
laisse les piscines tourner quand elles
sont avec des primes c'est là alors le
patrimoine le public qui paie le surcoût
ils vont augmenter les piscines
municipales c'est ce qu'on va livre
paraît que ça va ça va augmenter un jeu
facile municipal juste géraldine maillet
vous vous êtes tous d'accord et que
cette fermeture bah oui parce qu'on veut
je comprends que ce soit une décision
unilatérale est donc injuste je
comprends que ça pénalise les abonnés
les salariés les ateliers enfants par
exemple donc effectivement mais
concrètement comment ils font pour la
facture énergétique vers qui sont
obligés d'augmenter les abonnements
parce que quand ça passe de 15 millions
à 100 millions d'euros forcément qui
doit payer en fait il ya un effet de
l'improvisation c'était aussi à eux
d'anticiper une hausse de se courir sur
les marchés financiers avec tous les
mécanismes nous on le fait pour
l'approvisionnement de nos logements
sociaux de nos bâtiments là ils sont été
pris pris de court alors voilà le sujet
c'est plutôt une sub question de
principe quand on négocie un contrat on
s'y tient et la puissance publique le
service public doit se faire respecter
alors à rolle huard maire de nogent le
rotrou vous êtes surtout un exemple un
voilà c'est pour ça qu'on voulait vous à
voir ce soir avec nous parce que de ce
qui peut se passer dans les prochains
mois les prochaines semaines la
fermeture des piscines municipales plus
d'électricité moins de chauffage pénurie
d'ailleurs d'électricité complètement je
vous dise tu arrives et dans de grandes
villes comme à new york où d'autres très
grosse ville comme ça et on va remettre
ce qu'avait dit le président de la
république nous sommes en guerre et
florian philippot va venir nous
rejoindre et on aura donc cet économiste
qu'il y en avoir qui va nous expliquer
si on va avoir d'électricité cet hiver
raphaël beau roman c'est parti regardez
nous sommes en guerre
c'est un état de fait nous devons
l'énergie fait partie des instruments de
guerre utilisée par la russie et donc
nous devons absolument nous mettre en
situation de produire plus vite des
sources alternatives d'électricité alors
nous sommes en guerre c'est ce qu'a nié
président il a laissé entendre
d'ailleurs il y aurait une pénurie
d'électricité nous demandent à tous bien
sûr et à toutes de faire des efforts
forcément pour que ça ne se produise pas
est-ce que merci d'ailleurs merci d'être
là faille qui est déjà venu nous voir
qui est excellent merci beaucoup d'être
l' économie c'est qui va nous éclairer
là dessus et florian philippot vous vous
êtes connaisseurs vous êtes reconnaître
bonsoir vous êtes colère et pour vous
c'est pourquoi on en est là
on est là parce que le 3-3 moment il ya
depuis les années 90 avec l'union
européenne on a cassé notre système
énergétique c'est toutes les directives
européennes de libéralisation
on a fait le marché européen
d'électricité macron essayer de s'en
dépatouiller aujourd'hui il a plus là
c'est la commission européenne qui
décide
donc on a complètement bousillé un
système qui fonctionnait bien edf qui a
été créée juste après la guerre on avait
l'énergie moins cher nucléaire et ce à
deux macron première partie de mandat en
2018 nous dit je vais fermer 14
réacteurs nucléaires maintenant il nous
dit je vais en ouvrir 14 ans et il a
fermé effectivement fessenheim mais est
ce que c'est c'est quoi c'est la guerre
en ukraine qui nous amène là et
troisièmement la guerre en ukraine
pourquoi on dresser des téléspectateurs
concrètement pourquoi la guerre en
ukraine aujourd'hui nous impact mais
cela la guerre en ukraine c'est notre
réaction à la guerre en ukraine vous
savez ce sont les sanctions qui d'abord
ne servent à rien parce que ces
sanctions de toute façon on fait
exploser le prix d'énergie donc la
russie n'a jamais reçu autant d'argent
avec son énergie y compris l'union
européenne est son premier client il ya
une étude qui est sorti tout à l'heure
et est donc tout ça ne sert à rien ne
sert évidemment pas la paix par contre
ces sanctions soi disant anti russes se
sont révélés antilles françaises parce
que ça a fait exploser le prix de
l'énergie encore plus et aujourd'hui on
nous parle nous la france rappelle quand
même la france était le premier
exportateur net européen d'électricité
là maintenant on va avoir besoin
d'importer l'électricité parce qu'on a
des centrales fermé et parce que ya
cette affaire on va se retrouver on nous
dit on fermé piscine on vient de parler
des piscines avec trentaine je crois
qu'ils ont déjà fermé en france on nous
dit peut-être qu'il va falloir ne plus
chauffe et cédera fermé il ya déjà des
industries je sais quand même dramatique
aussi fort entre les arcs et cetera des
fonderies qui sont fermés d'ores et déjà
donc avec des milliers de salariés
français qui se retrouvent déjà
maintenant au chômage partiel on vous
pour vous pensez quoi que ça va on aura
pas de déficit et la tension continue
dans cette voie mais et notamment si on
continue avec les sanctions si on
continue à se passer de ce2 ce2 cette
énergie on irait donc on compte
continuer apparemment bah oui j'ai bien
compris parce que ça c'est ça c'est
macro et l'union européenne c'est à dire
qu'ils vont droit dans le mur donc les
droits qu'il arrive il voit le mur mais
ils font s'ils accélèrent il veut le
prendre en pleine figure on va se
prendre pour vous c'est quoi le mur en
pleine figure qui va se passer pour les
français qui nous regarde pas je ne sais
pas ce qui va se passer mais je crains
si vous les inquiets pas assez d'énergie
et 2 qui met en place un système de
restriction c'est vrai quand j'ai
entendu emmanuel macron nous dire nous
sommes en guerre merci il nous a déjà
fait le coup 1 mars 2020 sur le co vide
on a vu le résultat ça s'est traduit par
des confinement découvre des
restrictions des fermetures et ccg en
face pour avoir des choses comme ça bien
sûr c'était bien je donne les
informations très précises je demande
aux gens de se reporter un article du
parisien qui est sorti la semaine
dernière un long papier sur la carte
carbone d'accord qu'on peut appeler
parce énergétique moi j'allais rester si
depuis des mois alors ça veut dire que
quand vous faites vos achats votre carte
bleue vous dit en même temps voilà vous
avez vous en êtes là dans votre quota de
co2 si vous acheter de la viande à faire
ou si vous prenez l'avion ou si vous
allez dans un loisir réputé des
consommateurs de co2 et à un moment va
ça bloque ça s'appelle une carte carbone
alors le parisien en parler va-t-on
aller vers la carte carbone c'est-à-dire
impasse énergétique comme on a accepté
le principe d'un pass avant sanitaire
vaccinale pourquoi pas ce serait
incroyable c'est pas impossible 2
un pays comme les cos a publié en juin
mais quelques mois un plan l'irlande
pardon l'irlande bien je savais que
c'était l'irlande en disant si jamais il
ya une crise énergétique qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire et il ya des scénarios de
confinement énergétique en avait mais je
vous donne je juge je demande juste de
réfléchir macron a dit jean racine pour
moi il faut réduire de 10%
tout le monde doit vraiment réfléchir
c'est très sérieux macron a dit on va
réduire de on doit réduire de 10 % notre
consommation énergétique
moi je fais pas je savais qu'en 2020
vous savez combien alors il ya eu 2
confinement en 2020 de confinement des
couvre-feux des fermetures de
restaurants de salles de sport de cinéma
beaucoup moins de transport beaucoup
moins avions beaucoup moins de voix dans
les horaires vous savez de combien on a
réduit à mon sens une source à la nuit
oui alors il sait de combien on a réduit
la consommation d'énergie si la france
8,3 dans l'environnement confiné en
faisant rire en ayant de confinement ça
ne faisant rien donc là il nous demande
de réduire de 10% alors c'est pas
simplement le chauffage à 19 degrés un
peu moins de clim l'été est encore là
climont sera de moins en moins concerné
plus on va avancer dans la saison
pouvoir qui va nous permettre de réduire
de 6% ah ouais donc soit maxime ménez
fait moins de bois shing est ce que je
veux juste dire aux gens c'est que c'est
pas du tout inéluctable cette affaire
c'est pas une de plus de si vous laissez
pas c'est non mais c'est pas la nuée de
sauterelles qui arrive ou un séisme ou
l'ouragan entre comme une calamité
naturelle on à l'elysée si vous demandez
quoi vous demander d'arrêter les
sanctions contre l'ukraine tout se
passera bien par contre la russie et la
russie il faut arrêter ça et il faut non
mais il faut aussi réinvestir ce qui est
alors ségolène ait dit ce qu'elle a dit
dernièrement à ségou et aurélie elle est
pourquoi ces tunnels est souvent au
téléphone c'est une amie ségo elle est
aussi pour arrêter le conflit en ukraine
c'est qu'elle est si on se bat
sérieusement pour la paix ça sert à rien
de faire ces sanctions on se met autour
d'une table on discute du statut de
neutralité de l'ukraine on discute du
statut des républiques de l'est pourquoi
pas faire d'erreur va dans le mur là bon
on arrête avec l'otan qui est dans la
boue et russie ont plus en plus
guerrière on va dans le mur alors on va
complètement l'inclure dans le mur elle
a bien sûr avec maquereau ou voulez-vous
qu'on aille dans l'ue
on va dans le mur ouais intervient alors
même pire que ça dans le mur et on va
même c'est même pire que le mur s'ils
voulaient il peut y avoir un
effondrement économique et social de
notre pays et je vous assure que toucher
à l'énergie c'est probablement ce qui a
de plus douloureux pour les français il
faut bien en prendre conscience et
notamment les familles modestes se
chauffer c'est pas rien la version à
laver ça s'est marié au delà de ça c'est
aussi longtemps mais il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui sont venus de
localisation bah oui ils sont très
inquiets ils reviennent de vacances ils
se prennent ça dans aion l'isi date en
moi je me lève à 8 heures du matin je me
couche je me couche à 23 heures je
travaille tous les jours comme un chien
non seulement j'ai pas pour manger en
plus maintenant vu que j'aurais pas pu
me choper après demain
c'est pas très bon on a dit qu'on était
en guerre donc forcément là on nous dit
on va tous devoir tout réduire ses
comptes avec moi moi je moi je mange je
pense à tous les gens qui se réveille à
8 heures du matin qui se contracte et
qui travaille jusqu'à 3 et 12 heures par
jour et qui se dit je ne peux pas m'en
souviens je pouvais pas manger
maintenant je vais même plus beau
chanter et même plus pouvoir mettre
d'électricité on sait lire noir sur la
tête arrêter un moment où un moment un
moment un moment un moment un moment il
faut ici l'europe c'est très bien
conduit dans là parce que à l'époque
tous niveaux signature oui voilà la team
fmm est bon et on s'en fout ça
si l'avenir si belle vidéo mais qu'est
ce que tu as vu toi oui
toi par les vaccins
sont plus compétents qui était vu ça
serait quand même si c'est ça sera chez
telus con comme une [ __ ] avec tommy
sweet raphaël le professeur d'économie
on veut savoir ce qui va se passer en
france mine de rien on soir cyril
bonsoir jean raphaël excuses nous parce
que là j'en ai ras-le-bol et où tu sais
quoi qu'est ce qui se passe en france
actuellement est ce qu'on dit nous des
choses et dis nous ce qui va se passer
parce qu on est tous en restera alors
moi ce que je vais vous dire déjà c'est
que là vous parliez de lire un mot à la
mode c'est le mot sobriété et vous il ya
déjà des ménages effectivement qui ont
du mal à se chauffer bien sûr dans des
passoires thermiques dont l'énergie pèse
beaucoup sur le budget et donc ça qui
leur permet de sobriété lors qu'ils sont
déjà en des fixes et ça fait des années
c'est une sobriété subi en l'occurrence
mais on est quand même dans une
situation cette année qui est inédite et
qui est assez grave en termes de
production d'électricité en france on a
32 réacteurs qui sont en maintenance
dont 12 pour des problèmes de corrosion
c'est-à-dire de fissures
avec quoi rien à voir avec l'ukraine ah
ben non alors la russie a commencé avant
la même 32 réacteurs en maintenance sur
56 réacteurs ça n'a rien à voir avec
l'ukraine mais ça pénalise la production
d'électricité en france n'a comme ça
mais des tensions sur la production
d'électricité c'est intéressant voilà
merci
pour le gall vous avez un fournisseur de
la france en l'occurrence la russie qui
représente 17 % du gaz consommé en
français qui alors monsieur philippe
odile faux pas de sanction contre la
russie moi je suis prof d'économie je
suis pas prof de géo politique mais ce
que je pense c'est que il faut il faut
faire un scénario sans gaz russe de
toute façon parce que si c'est pas
l'europe tu mets des sanctions sur la
russie c'est le président poutine qui
risquent de d'arrêter de vendre du gaz à
l'europe de toute façon donc il faut se
préparer à ce scénario se préparer à ce
scénario ça veut dire consommer moins de
gaza veut dire chercher d'autres pour
d'autres approvisionnements
alors on a commencé à chercher mais il
ya un défaut d'anticipation clairement
d'accord il ya un problème sur les prix
c'est à dire que le prix du gaz il a été
multiplié par 20 en un an sur le marché
de gros du gaz et celui du christ et par
12 il a dépassé les 1000 euros le
mégawattheure la semaine dernière donc
ça veut dire qu'il ya un vrai problème
de prix mais comme enfoncé un bouclier
tarifaire jusqu'à la fin de l'année les
ménages français sont protégés et ne
subissent pas c'est au cette hausse de
prix mais les entreprises les piscines
et industrie et où elles ont des
différentes et justement rafael vous
poser bien le problème là parce que
c'est la question que je me pose est
est-ce que les particuliers peuvent être
impactés par ce serait cette pénurie
d'électricité est-ce que ça va être que
les entreprises où est ce que les
ménages français qui nous regardent vont
être impactés alors je vais vous
répondre clairement cyril répondait
brignolais d'électricité en 2006 on a eu
15 millions de foyers en europe qu'il ya
un moment ce qu'on appelle un black out
c'est à dire qu'il y avait plus
d'électricité par an on a des images de
black-out moi comme ça vous allez voir
ce qui peut se passer éventuellement
vous allez voir ça fait flipper j'ai
l'impression d'être dans la chambre de
mathieu devant monique au dos alors
regardez
je lis faire lopez est en plein concert
au madison square garden au coeur de new
york
quand soudain
[Applaudissements]
une panne d'électricité géante à 18h47
c'est tout l'ouest de new york qui vient
de connaître un black out total ou
presque qui va durer plus de quatre
heures
dans les rues les feux rouges ne
fonctionne plus la circulation se
transforme par endroits en chaos en
quelques minutes des embouteillages
monstres se crée dans les sous sols
certaines stations de métro sont plongés
dans le noir les lignes sont à l'arrêt
les passagers doivent évacuer par
milliers
ça c'est chaud ça ça c'est chaud ça ça
peut arriver ça enfin alors justement
moi je suis pas madame soleil donc je
peux faire des prévisions à madame
soleil c'est castaldi
faire les prévisions mais moi ce que je
peux vous dire c'est qu'on n'a jamais eu
32 réacteurs en maintenance plus des
problèmes d'approvisionnement du gaz
donc c'est une situation inédite
catastrophique inédite les graves et
donc il faut se mobiliser et pourquoi le
gars ça pose un problème parce que le
gars c'est pas simplement pour consommer
du gaz c'est aussi pour produire
d'électricité donc si vous importez
d'électricité un pays qui l'a produit à
partir du gaz et qu'il ya moins de gaz
et à des tensions son marché de
l'électricité au si vous voyez ce que je
veux dire non le gain est utilisé aussi
pour produire de l'électricité quand ya
des tensions sur le gaz ça pèse sur la
production d'électricité parce que là
c'est plus clair et les sourires les gas
gas quoi ses premiers clients surtout
nom mathieu en europe et à des
importations exportations d'électricité
et il ya des centrales électriques en
europe du produisent à partir du gaz cet
oxyde il ya des tensions sur le gaz
russe ou sur le marché du gaz ça peut
rendre difficile la production
d'électricité aussi donc le gaz peut
procès un problème en termes de
production d'électricité et donc
contribuer au black ainsi indirectement
alors injustement non les français qui
nous regardent il est 21h on est on est
en direct on se pose cette question
aura-t-on de l'électricité cet hiver on
voit de plus en plus de choses qu'on
avait jamais vu avant se produire là il
ya une piscine qui vient d'être fermé on
nous demande de faire des efforts c'est
de baisser de 10% je suis pas du tout ce
que ça correspond à quoi ça correspond à
10% mais le chiffre que vous avez donnée
lorsqu'on était en confinement le ca a
baissé de 8 2% ce que vous avez dit donc
c'est alors qu'on ne sait rien ça ça
fait flipper la ja raphaël boromo qui
nous dit qu'on n'a jamais eu une
situation aussi catastrophique avec une
trentaine voilà vous nous avez dit de
ceux de deux réacteurs à l'inde à
certains vont repartir avant l'hiver
quand même il ya cet espoir cet espoir
donc là aujourd'hui on est le 6
septembre est ce qu'à votre avis vous
qui êtes un économiste sérieux est-ce
que vous pensez que cet hiver là c'est à
dire à horizon novembre décembre ou même
pour les fêtes de noël est ce que vous
pensez qu'il va y avoir de grosses
restrictions est ce que vous pensez que
tous les foyers français pourront avoir
de l'électricité ou est-ce que ça va pas
augmenter oui bah ça augmente et oui
justement mais le truc c'est que à un
moment et les gens pourront plus payer
en bas là il ya deux questions
différentes alors ya la question alors
faisons le compte de la pénurie alors ça
le volume sur la première question a
priori il n'y aura pas de blague de de
pénurie d'électicité pour les ménages
d'accord peut y avoir ce qu'on appelle
du délestage c'est-à-dire des coupures
localisées dans port ra exceptionnel
pour des sites industriels d'accord s'il
ya soit assez d'électricité voilà c'est
à dire donc au site alors qu'il ya des
entreprises qui ont des contrats qu'on
appelle des contrats interruptible des
contrats d'effacement les acceptent de
ne pas consommer de l'électricité à un
moment quand il ya des tensions sur
l'offre d'électricité et la production
d'accord donc ça c'est très probable ça
c'est très probable ça va aller ça peut
arriver comme ça ça peut arriver alors
la consommation d'électricité dépend de
la production industrielle est aussi de
la météo pour leur ménage donc à chaque
degré de froid supplémentaire à on a
besoin de produire davantage on y fait
très chanson sur toute la france c'est
pousser sa sas alors effectivement le
problème va se poser plutôt l'hiver
dacalor même si à la climatisation en
été dont un siège où est le problème
c'est que l'électricité ne se stocke pas
à la différence des autres à la défiance
du gaz ou du pétrole assez intéressant
voilà donc il faut un équilibre en temps
réel entre l'offre et la demande donc si
tout le monde consomme à un moment et
qu'on peut pas produire suffisamment il
ya il peut y avoir un problème de black
out c'est à dire de pénurie à un moment
instantané ça peut arriver ça voilà
alors que sur le gaz on a des stocks en
france qui représente 90 % qui sont
remplis à 90% mais les stocks gaziers ne
représentent que 25 % la consommation de
bière tsonga en gars ça devrait aller ou
pas on bien ça devrait bien se passer en
électricité où il ya des exemples et
vous êtes amenés en gaz pour les
industriels ça peut être tendu aussi
parce que les stocks ne représentent
même s'ils sont remplies presque à 100%
que 25 % la consommation de viande
française alors moi j'ai une question
posée est ce qu'on va pas dans ce qu'il
est possible qu'on demande aux ménages
français un moment des revoilà de de
dire 'voilà partir d'une certaine heure
plus d'électricité alors c'est arrivé
dans les années 70 un plan après le choc
pétrolier où on avait des mesures qui
ont été prises il ya le japon après la
catastrophe nucléaire de fukushima
pareil cas mis en place un plan de
rationnement alors on parle de guerre
économique dont on dit qu'il faut être
en économie de guerre alors tout ça ça
casse beaucoup l'ambiance mais on va
dire que ça il faut une économie un peu
de de rationnement pour ceux qui le
peuvent et éviter le gaspillage
énergétique cette année et à l'avenir
que ce soit à cause de la crise
énergétique ou % par rapport au
réchauffement climatique mais pour
sauver la planète oui à arles due à un
mètre maire de nogent le rotrou il veut
nous voir aujourd'hui je vous rappelle
si vous nous rejoignez parce que il a vu
sa piscine municipale fermée donc ça
commence vraiment voilà a chauffé où il
voulait dire quelque chose bah je pense
que l' avantage de l'électricité c'est
que ça s'ajuste plus vite que le gaz
c'est à dire on ferme une piscine c'est
l'équivalent de la consommation de 1000
habitants d'accord on ferme une très
grosse usine avec des compartiments
réfrigérés dans l'agroalimentaire on
arrête la production l'entreprise
continue d'écouler ses stocks ont fait
un mois de chômage pour les deux partiel
pour les salariés et là aussi on
récupère l'équivalent de 1000 1500
habitants donc c'est des choses qu'on a
qu'on sait organiser et sur lequel on
travaille avec les préfectures depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois d'accord oui
ferait faillite je rappelle que la
isabelle borne le premier ministre a dit
qu'il pouvait y avoir aussi des coupures
pour les particuliers d'électricité et
des coupures de deux heures c'est ça je
le dis quand même parce que c'est la
sueur du norisring plus doxa sur 7 je
serai quoi ça des coupures de deux
heures ils se passeraient quoi il ya eu
c'est quand même c'est quoi c'est en
pleine après l'aventuré un quartier puis
15-4 côté on sait pas il peut y en avoir
le matin il peut y avoir l'après-midi
l'on me donnait des bornes horaires bon
enfin bon tout ça quand même là ça
fonctionne à fond c'est quand même le
premier producteur mondial d'électricité
qui était premier exportateur mondial
non mais je dis un décompte de l'ats du
niveau de folie je veux quand même que
les gens entendent aussi ce qu'a dit
macro hier macro hier
macro hier je vous fais cet effet
bakou
alors je continue ma croyère a dit
quelque chose je vais quand même désolé
je vais un peu cassé l'ambiance casser
l'ambiance mettre un peu de clim dans
l'ambiance d'un cran hier annonce
quelque chose de très grave il nous dit
avec l'accord européen la du 26 juillet
on peut donner du gaz à l'allemagne on
va donner du gars de l'allemagne mais je
vous signale c'est france info qui a
sorti le sujet hier que y compris si
nous on en manque et compris au
détriment et ça vous fait rire mais ça
devrait ce à quoi il a dit cink prix au
détriment des wagonnets on va donner
notre de duke à livrer du gaz à
l'allemagne y compris si on en france y
compris si les particuliers et les
entreprises il ya peut-être jochen
schmidt il va avoir du gaz directement
jean françois buisson non
[Applaudissements]
mais que les français parce que la
hongrie s'est très bien normal que les
français soient extrêmement exigeants
quand même prix on a cassé leurs
systèmes énergétiques qu'ils ont payé
c'est l'union européenne c'est tous ces
dirigeants là mais après après
il ya des événements qu'on contrôle pas
non non non je suis désolé oui il ya
toujours des éléments contre pas enfin
les réponses on les contrôle oui je sais
voilà donc jamais le calme toi vous
auriez répond l'union à chaque fois
douze mois les spécialistes
une française comme tout le monde j'ai
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui quand vous
prenez la parole et vous à 10h c'est
toujours pour vous tirer des balles a
depuis maintenant parce que moi je me
dis ça m'a pris mais ce que je dis la
même chose sur la durée moi j'étais
saoul et dans le conseil régional grand
test je me suis battu contre la
fermeture de fessenheim pour c'était
alors la guerre c'est qu'il faut
investir juste fils à ma direction dix
ukrainiens d'arrêter de se battre ça va
pas nous donner un kilowatt heure devant
mais vous croyez une seule seconde les
ukrainiens avec cette affaire d'ailleurs
le les gars c'est poutine qui l'a voulu
c'est poutine qui retire les bénéfices
et qui en dernière est restée nous il
faut réagir un crédit d'un haut niveau à
réagir en ne servant pas la donne est
d'ailleurs l'autre
je ne suis pas d'accord pour qu'on se
tire une balle dans la tête alors qu'on
serre la paix on ne serre pas la paix on
ne cesse de mètres de haut laissant nos
intérêts enfin notez bien là mon ami
giro et notre liberté en faisant des
récipiendaires
non mais attendez à ces symptômes ainsi
l'ensemble
mais on peut plus y aller parce qu'elle
est fermé sa piscine wings et maintenant
je veux bien qu'on soit dans la
novlangue à la même langue permanente
mais vous pouvez pas appelé liberté ce
qui nous attend est ce qu'on a vécu
depuis deux ans et demi on nous a parlé
accord et rationnement de restriction
abandon mais aussi la monture et vous
dites c'est pour avoir la liberté mais
non plus on allume qu'il
trouve que c'est très grave ce qui se
passe en fait j'ai l'impression qu'après
locaux vides on a trouvé le nouveau truc
pour faire peur aux français à l'elysée
pour les priver de leur liberté et au
delà des conséquences immédiates qui
sont cons et rappeler la piscine qu'on
devra - se chauffer cet été je trouve
que ça envoie un signal horrible d'une
société en bout de course à l'arrêt où
on ne peut plus rien faire et je pense
que c'est un climat anxiogène déprimant
et je me mets à la place des jeunes
vraiment c'est très difficile de voir où
je t'ai tube d'entre nous de croire en
l'avenir quand on a un président qui
nous sort des nous sommes en guerre
j'aimerais avoir des professionnels la
cie pour entendre des conneries
pareilles
juste eux ou ce qu'on veut savoir est ce
que les français veulent savoir à 21h05
en direct quels sont les risques raphaël
faites nous un résumé en cinq minutes
alors français qu'il en garde qu'est ce
qui va se passer est ce moi pouvoir
décorer notre sapin de noël c'est ça va
augmenter à les dominer annoncé question
après question a loupé anne sinclair l'a
donc sur sur le volume ça fait trente
minutes il va falloir se remplacer
l'approvisionnement rustock la france et
l'europe il travaille déjà mais il ya
des stocks de gaz il ya du gaz naturel
liquéfié qui livrait en france est-ce
que c'est oui ou non donc tout moment
quoi on voir des ports et non simplement
ont je pense qu'on peut s'en sortir pour
le gaz et pour l'électricité pour les
prix il va falloir impact est
malheureusement une partie la hausse des
prix du marché sur la facture des
ménages si ils font la totalité la
facture va doubler je pense qu'ils vont
limiter à la fin du bouclier tarifaire à
10 ou 20% de dégâts énormes je le sais
mais bon c'est pas moi qui ai l'esprit
aurait déjà doublé 6 mai
alors les dix ans en grande bretagne les
plus de 80 % sur la facture au 1er
octobre et en allemagne ils vont
augmenter de 40% en france pour
l'instant on est à zéro jusqu'à fin
d'année et si on n'est jamais à venir
d'ailleurs et si on n'a pas de gaz est
ce qu'on pourra donner a annoncé
koutchma alors on fait du gaz monsieur
twitter en fait l'idée c'est plutôt si
l'industrie allemande a besoin de gaz et
la france peut par solidarité européenne
et pour défendre ses intérêts livrer du
gaz à l'allemagne et à l'industrie alain
souviendra pas si c'est non non ma masse
et non mais ça permet d'aider la justice
française aussi cinq ans il ya des liens
économiques entre les pays non non c'est
pas pensé nationalisme énergétique pense
à ça maintenant on va pas manquer de
galles et de
suggérer d'aller donner du gaz quand
nous on en entend pas du national il
avait aimé
ça s'appelle une trahison des intérêts
nationaux non il faut que les gens
soient extrêmement exigeants vis-à-vis
de ceux qui les dirigent parce que c'est
eux qui les ont bien dans cette
situation nationale en bois puis se
chauffer cet hiver être soumis à des
restrictions etc ces macro et toute sa
clique c'est pas les français quand j'en
ai seulement qui manque de gaz mais on
va peut-être un meilleur sentiment avoir
manqué d'électricité c'est ça qui est ça
qui est de la solidarité entre européens
et l'allemagne vont à l'électricité ou
pas alors l'allemagne justement il
souffre comme le reste
ce type à leur guide je te donne un peu
de gazon n'a pas l'électricité
c'est ce que fait le président mais
voilà ça tu vois pas voilà non l'idée
c'est de dire l'allemagne si on a trop
de vias passion ne l'a pas assez
d'accord et électricité ils peuvent pas
nous donner l'électricité les allemands
on importe déjà avec le site et
d'allemagne et d'autres pays dont il ya
des échanges de nous on a un peu un
homme un peu plus assis a besoin il ya
des interconnexions pour le faire donc
elle en est ce que tu es confiant on pas
moi je suis confiant je pense que sur
guillaume a raison il faut pas être
anxiogène par rapport en leur temps de
sa carrière a décidé jeudi qu'il faut se
mobiliser il faut faire attention et ne
pas gaspiller l'électricité ou perdre je
pourrais l'appeler la question
je voudrais après faut que je
réfléchisse dix mois la vérité arrêter
d'y jouer pendant quelques temps parce
que j'allume la dette parce que c'est
parce que parions parions aussi c'est
vrai que l'on peut ne pas allumer la
lumière aux toilettes si c'est une led
ou si c'est une non pas des charges
l'obligation c'est vrai je sers à rien
de regarder ton
[Applaudissements]
l'argent ça tous les jours est ce que
par exemple
d'utiliser mon le moins le micro ondes
les les chargeurs de tels tout ça non
par exemple ils ont dit sur le chauffage
par exemple chaque degré en moins c'est
7 % d'économie d'accord peut on peut
mettre à 19 comme la loi le dit pour cet
attentisme des gâchis qu'on peut éviter
maintenant comme dit guillaume du gène
et le confort des gens et où est ce que
dira c'est le gâchis qu'il faut éviter
c'est est ce que vous pensez qu'ils vont
fermer toutes les piscines municipales
très vite ça c'est ce qu'ils disent ça
je peux pas vous le dire je laisse le
maire répond paul et à mon avis c'est
vrai que la ripisylve ça c'est des
arbitrages met dans les pas moi je
préside à l'office de hlm si on tombait
à 19 1 1 degré en moins dans l'est dans
un bâtiment public c'est 7 % d'économie
eu de grands - et 15% des collections
refait l'isolation c'est 40 % des
commandes moi moi donc il ya quand même
des solutions yade élue les choses je
pense aux français qui ont un budget qui
est très très très serré et ils disent
nous il ya des budgets qui se joue à 10
20 euros par mois je vous dis j voilà
des gens que je connaissais tu joues à
10 20 euros par mois avec l'électricité
qui va augmenter le gaz qui va augmenter
on voit les sens avait fortement
augmenté aussi la 7eme mieux on se dit
déjà que l'hiver est dure généralement
pour ces gens là et qu'ils arrivent à
manger jusqu'au 20 20 ans témoigne
encore ccc pour les voilà les ccc ccc le
maximum comment ils vont faire vraiment
pour s'en sortir et c'est ce que me
demande également mon ami tu rodriguez
qui m'écrit là comment ils vont faire
pour s'en sortir c'est ça moi c'est pour
ces gens là vraiment et toutes les
personnes voilà qui nous regardent qui
sont qui travaillent sous lycée qui
travaillent tous les jours 10 heures par
jour et qui n'arrivent pas à s'en sortir
c'est ça le plus gros drame qu'on vit en
ce moment ces six personnes qui
travaillent dix heures par jour et
qu'ils disent le soir je peux pas manger
je ne peux pas faire manger mes enfants
ici je peux pas chauffer mes enfants
quand ils vont faire alors il ya 12
millions de français qui sont très car
et énergétique oui nos qualités c'est le
fait d'avoir gelé avec le bouquet
tarifaires les prix jusqu'à la fin de
l'année c'est que ça les impacts un peu
moins que si on avait répercuté la
hausse des prix du marché mais l'idée
pour l'année prochaine c'est si les
factures augmentent de 10% cdd d'avoir
des aides ciblées avec des chèques
énergie ces ménages là c'est pas la
peine d'aider tout le monde est
saupoudré il faut concentrer les moyens
la sueur projet plus on exalte aux
blessés la solidarité si on laisse
chacun face à son fournisseur celui qui
a des employés qui consommaient où il ya
celui qui a des trous dans tu sais ce
qu'il va y avoir des aides pour les plus
démunis sur la marionnette déjà sur le
gaz ce qui va en avoir encore plus alors
il ya quand il ya les carburants qui ont
augmenté 6 centimes ya eu des mouvements
de gilet jaune pendant plusieurs mois
donc s'il n'aide pas il y aura des
grosses difficultés sociales le bouclier
tarifaire a coûté 24 milliards d'euros à
l'état pour protéger le pouvoir d'achat
mais il faut continuer à aider les
ménages en ciblant les ménages les plus
en difficulté les aides sur les
carburants concerne tout le monde est ce
que vous vous avez besoin des 30
centimes sur le carburant comme un
ménage au nord-est ne sont pas besoin
voilà donc si on cible c'est bien besoin
de rien c'est bien son nom on est là on
peut vivre ici et puis vous venez pour
passer il faut des aides ciblées alors
il d'ores et déjà je suis pas dans les
hlm de ma ville de nogent le rotrou ci
avait pas eu de bouclier tarifaire
négocier avec qui tu es comme c'est
chauffé au gaz collectif il ya des gens
qui gagne 1300 euros par mois qui aurait
eu 900 euros de plus s'il n'y avait pas
eu ça donc voilà il ya déjà quelque
chose de fait la question c'est combien
de temps ça peut durer et combien de
temps dans le temps on est capable de
tenir dans une quête une économie de
guerre mais ce qui nous ramène n'ont pas
forcément à la guerre mais à ce qu'on a
vécu sur le choc pétrolier ou encore il
ya trente ans où l'économie était
administré il y avait un état qui
organise et les choses et qu'ils
prenaient les choses en un mois merci en
tout cas merci d'avoir éclairé dont il
n'y a pas d'inquiétude à lyon à brest et
il faut rester mobilisé sur moi quand
même enfin ouais bah c'est pas la fête
ces accords